one year ago today if you can leave that
Hurricane Maria slammed into Puerto Rico
with sustained winds of 155 miles an
hour a recent study from George
Washington University estimates nearly
3,000 people died that died from the
hurricane President Trump believes the
death toll is inflated though and later
today there will be a ceremony to
commemorate the storms anniversary David
Wagner was in Puerto Rico when the
deadly category 4 hurricane made
landfall the winds are ferocious right
now gusting above 120 miles per hour
well for the past year david has been
following the recovery efforts and
recently returned to the island for a
new CBS n documentary about the disaster
David good morning I know for a lot of
us we say can we believe it's a year
I'll bet you can believe that it's been
a year it's a somber day I'm sure it's a
somber day I remember so well be on
front of that hotel a year ago good
morning our team started working on this
documentary sometime around the spring
it was driven by the fact that after all
the reporting we had done one to two
minutes on television just it just
didn't seem like enough to convey how
bad things really were we saw an
unbelievable struggle and a
determination to be heard
Puerto Rico is a Commonwealth of the
United States so its residents are
American citizens now they can relocate
without any restrictions it's estimated
that nearly half of the people who have
left the island so far are under the age
of 24 and that's a demographic that is
the lifeblood of any labor force but
despite that we met some residents that
believe it's still possible for Puerto
Rico to get back on its feet
I like your gray hair finally somebody
else who's young with gray hair this
group of inspiring young professionals
and artists believe that right now maybe
Puerto Rico's best chance to reshape
this island for the better about 7 days
after the storm someone said to me Maria
maybe the best thing that happened to
Puerto Rico it shocked me think it's
true
same thing like we have gotten stronger
if anyone had a now and now that what
Porto Ricans are struggling on their own
this is a country that has been fighting
for its
what does it mean to be Puerto Rico what
that is a colony of the United States so
you can't separate that it's part of you
were born in a conics country the
context of Minea it's about realizing
that you're on your own that your
government won't do the work the country
that has colonized your country willing
to do the work would you rather be an
independent country or but but the u.s.
is already committed I think close to 50
billion dollars right so I mean it's
huge a lot of people contributed money
towards Puerto Rico and its recovery
where's the money when I still have
sleep over that power or portable water
for that matter so that clip shows
Puerto Ricans who are staying they don't
want to leave the island but there are a
lot of people who are leaving because
for them it's just too difficult to stay
I have to tell you I've never
experienced an endless emergency like
the one that Maria left behind though
things are now in a recovery mode a lot
of the people who are leaving are single
parents moms and dads and we're gonna
profile a single mom in our story who
decided to leave with her daughter with
no promise of anything on the mainland
no she said I gotta go I gotta go do you
have any idea of the numbers of people
that left Puerto Rico what that number
is and what are you hearing about their
plans to return close to 198,000 did and
of that 198,000 about 40,000 kids have
not registered in school it's
interesting to hear young people say
they feel like they're on their own and
in some cases they would prefer to be on
their own absolutely listen Anthony I
was surprised because the governor will
tell you hey we support statehood we had
two referendums the voter turnout was
near 23% right so it's hard to say the
majority claimed that but I was
surprised with those people at the table
who said I think I want independence
because everything that I've grown up
with I'm not sure I want the u.s. I'm
not sure I want to be a part of the US I
was surprised I didn't expect to hear
that they're still asking for a bailout
from the US government too though and
the helping that comes with fair but
fair but remember they pay taxes it's
their money it's not a gift yeah they
pay taxes it's theirs
and we're of those 200,000 people
relocated to the Orlando New York
Massachusetts 38 different states but
there's such a large contingent in
Central Florida and here in New York
City quite frankly yeah order because a
beautiful place would like to see a man
to its original glory
thank you David you bet Puerto Rico the
Exodus after Hurricane Maria will stream
tomorrow at 10:00 p.m. Central
8:00 Pacific on CBS n